What's up guys welcome back. I'm Grant Thompson The King of Random. I'm Brian Brushwood from the Modern Rogue
And did you know that during the American Civil war soldiers would go out and get brass knuckles or steel knuckles?
But if they weren't available, they would take bullets and melt them down for the lead content to make a pair of lead knuckles
using the enemy's ammunition against them right in their faces, for this project
We thought it would be fun to replicate that experiment although, we don't have any ammunition
yeah, but this is fishing Country Central, Texas. We got plenty of lead fishing weights. Here's the theory
We're going to take some play-doh and build kind of a little base that will accommodate play sand. Now Brian got this play
out of his kids play pit. So we thank you for the donation
Brian's family
Once the sand is packed in there in the consistency of about Sandcastle sand we want to dig out
Something that resembles the mold for brass knuckles
we're going to melt down the fishing weights with a propane torch and
Carefully pour it into that mold and let it set and see if we can make ourselves an improvised pair of knuckles
that's not safe
so what we've done here is we've fashioned a retaining wall all the way around the edge of this rock and
We put a little play doh bottom in there as well
We're gonna go get some sand Moisten it down pack it down there and really good
And then we're gonna carve out the groove of the type of knuckles
We want to make hard to not just keep touching it it feels real good. It does feel really good all right
What do you think?
I think this is looking pretty good
So we're not sure if this is gonna work or not
But we're using play-doh stubbs to represent the fingers so the question is will a Molten lead flow around the Play-doh
Or will it just take it out cause like this is actually yeah, I'm kind of thinking it will actually just float up
oh, what if we put a stick across now. It's time to look like a proper mold
there we go
Okay, cool. So we got a really rough mold set
This is just proof of concept we're not going for perfection here, but now that we've got our mold ready
Let's go ahead and melt the let pour it in and just see if we can get this thing to even work at all
Oh Wow! It looks exactly like it's done
Those are brass knuckles. That's already solidified
Yeah, just like that. I think I think we got a winner so we literally just poured this stuff and it looks amazing
It's already factory finished
So we're just gonna rip it out of the mold it's still really hot, but I can't believe it's already solidified
Yeah, no, no, I would imagine look
I don't want to get punched in the face by these no
And I don't think they're perfect but I think for proof of concept this is pretty good
Oh my God 100% let's see what we got
This is all hard already. We pulled the stick out our little retaining device. Look at that. Is it burning you at all? No?
Cool
Look at that. oh
Grant it's perfect. Oh wow
So you can actually just pop the play-doh. Yeah, and we have our finger holes, whoa
whaaaat!
That worked unbelievably well! lead knuckles are nothing wow. I am so surprised that the Play-doh held up to the lead
Yeah, I thought it would have caught on fire and just incinerated it look at that
Wow, I'm gonna touch yeah. Oh my gosh. Is that still hot? What are you really ah?
does that actually fit your hand? yes! It fits perfectly
try this try this this is amazing first try. I cannot believe it was that simple. Let's go clean these things up. Yeah, you got it
Do we even need to use the sand or could We just make the mold out of the Play-doh itself?
It's an awesome psychedelic mold it is look at that. That's cool.
Oh wait, that's how we make it. Yeah, don't worry
[laughing] how easy is that?
The Civil war soldiers should of probably, they should have been using play-doh. What were they thinking? oh, that's ideal
Space things looking okay to me there
its bubbling
Oh Wow, is it leaking do you think?
I Think it's uh removing the water from the, oh the water is boiling off. Yeah I think the water steaming
Well at least gives us a reason for the sand, but that looks great though. I think it just solidified right there.
smoking!
let's pull this thing apart and see how we did. well the nice thing is it just peels back Huh? look at that
uh, it's got some slimy residues. Its left the psychedelic ehh buzz all around it look at that
Oh look at that actually it's not it's not as hot as you'd think it cools off pretty fast right well our playdough
Placeholders seemed to serve their purpose guys
This is unbelievable, so these are the ones that just came out of the play-doh. They're rough
But you know what if you put a little more time into making your mold. oh it would look amazing, and look at this
Let's work the fingers through there these things are legit
The best part is once you've made one good pair that becomes your basis for all your copies, right?
So once you make one pair you just use it and push it down in the play-doh and push it in there you got an
Instant mold this is the one that we made using sand and you can see how it's really coarse on the bottom
It's actually a pretty cool texture comes out nice and smooth on the top though where everything levels out and the one that we made
with the Play-doh comes out a little bit smoother, so a couple cool options
It's amazing to see how quickly this came together
Especially when we really didn't spend much time on them at all. question, Do you think when I slammed this down
Do you think these will buckle under? well That's good point. You could try yeah, all right you ready, yeah.
oooohhhhh
This is tough, wow! look at that you can see a dent in it, but it it is not going anywhere
Wow, these are tough pretty cool. So apparently this is a very viable idea it really does work
Yeah, we use Play-doh
And sand that I could totally see using clay and just some random stuff you found on the ground to create these bad boys you
Could probably even do it with cow poop you know what you can do it with cow poo
I may be from Texas and I have my limits sir
as we prove that this concept really does work now of course knuckledusters like these are illegal in most states including the state of
Texas so we're just gonna melt these down and use them for lead ingots instead
But you can see how this idea is very plausible and can be duplicated very easily and Mr.
Brian brushwood anything you want to tell the folks before we go. Hey come check out our channel
We're on a quest to become the ultimate Modern rogues. I think you'll dig it
I'll put his link down in the description so go check them out, and as for you guys we looking for the next project
talk to you then
[laughing]
remember this trick to use Play-doh to pick up Play-doh